If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click Gifts. Canada's Wonderland is bringing the holiday magic this season with Winterfest on select nights now through January 3rd. Step into a winter wonderland filled with millions of dazzling lights, festive shows, rides and holiday treats. Plus, Coca-Cola is back with Canada's kindness community, celebrating acts of kindness nationwide, with a chance at 100,000 donation for the winning community
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即一切”俱乐部。随着圣诞节的临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”即可。加拿大奇幻乐园（Canada's Wonderland）在这个节日季通过“冬季庆典”（Winterfest）为您带来节日魔法，活动时间为即日起至1月3日的特定夜晚。步入一个充满数百万璀璨灯光、节日表演、游乐设施和节日美食的冬季仙境。此外，可口可乐公司携手加拿大的“善意社区”回归，在全国范围内庆祝善举，获胜社区还有机会获得10万捐款。
and a 2026 holiday caravan stop. Learn more at canadaswunderland.com. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionized the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity
以及2026年节日大篷车的停靠站。欲了解更多信息，请访问canadaswunderland.com。本集由Hive赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大彻底改变了未来。但现在，您可以利用Hive的力量改变自己的能源未来并掌控一切。Hive充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，
and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV Charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution.
并使您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。Hive的恒温器让您无需动一根手指，只需轻轻一点，就能轻松调节家中温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在您想要的精确位置。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive的电动汽车充电器让您的汽车在夜间安静充电，在您休息的同时完成充电。Hive将供暖、充电和太阳能集于一身，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，实现了一场安静的革命。
In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. hive app compatible with selected technology Paid for surplus requires SEG tariff Dear boss I keep on hearing the police have caught me where they won't fix me just yet I've laughed when they look so clever
在漫长的能源历史中，Hive帮助您最终掌握自己的能源。前往hivehome.com了解更多信息，具体取决于勘测和适用性。Hive应用程序兼容选定技术。支付盈余需要SEG关税。亲爱的老板，我一直听说警察抓到我了，但他们还没能抓住我。当他们看起来很聪明时，我笑了，
and talk about being on the ride track That joke about leather apron gave me real fits. I'm down on whores, and I shan't quit ripping them till I do get buckled. Grand work, the last job was. I gave the lady no time to squeal. How can they catch me now? I love my work, and I want to start again. You will soon hear of me with my funny little games.
谈论着在轨道上。关于“皮围裙”（Leather Apron）的那个笑话让我真的发狂了。我讨厌妓女，在被抓之前我不会停止撕裂她们。最后那次工作干得漂亮。我没给那位女士尖叫的时间。他们现在怎么抓得住我？我热爱我的工作，我想重新开始。你很快就会听到我那些有趣的小游戏。
I saved some of the proper red stuff in a ginger beer bottle over the line. last job to write with, but it went thick like glue, and I can't use it. Red ink is fit enough, I hope. The next job I do, I shall clip the lady's ears off and send to the police officers just for jolly, wouldn't you? Keep this letter back till I do a bit more work, then give it out straight. My knife's so nice and sharp. I want to get to work right away if I get a chance. Good luck. yours truly jack the ripper don't mind me giving the trade name p s wasn't good enough to post this before i got all the red ink of my hands curse it no luck yet they say i'm a doctor now ah ah so that's the most notorious the most infamous letter in the history of crime and of course it's so chilling because of the mocking sadistic tone, the tone almost of banter.
我把一些真正的“红东西”保存在线上的姜汁啤酒瓶里，留着写最后一次工作，但它变得像胶水一样浓，我没法用了。希望红墨水够用。下次工作时，我会剪掉那位女士的耳朵，寄给警察，只是为了好玩，难道不是吗？把这封信留着，等我再做点工作后再发出去。我的刀又好又快。如果有机会，我想马上开始工作。祝好运。您真诚的，开膛手杰克。别介意我用了这个绰号。附：在我把手上的红墨水洗干净之前，没法寄出这封信，该死，还没运气。他们说我现在是个医生，啊啊。所以，这就是犯罪史上最臭名昭著、最声名狼藉的信件。当然，它之所以令人不寒而栗，是因为那种嘲弄、施虐的语气，几乎是一种调侃的语气。
And it was sent on the 27th of September 1888 to the Central News Agency of London. And they sat on it for two days, unsure whether it was authentic, and then forwarded it to Scotland Yard. And this is the letter, Tom, that gives the name to somebody who at that point had killed probably two, possibly three, possibly more women. on the streets of Whitechapel, in an area of the east end of London that was notorious for poverty and crime and prostitution. And both of these women had had their throats cut and both had been hideously mutilated.
这封信于1888年9月27日寄往伦敦中央新闻社。他们扣留了两天，不确定其真实性，随后将其转交给了苏格兰场。汤姆，就是这封信给那个当时可能已经杀害了两名、可能三名、甚至更多女性的人取了名字。在白教堂的街道上，在伦敦东区一个以贫困、犯罪和卖淫而臭名昭著的地区。这两名女性都被割断了喉咙，且都遭到了极其残忍的毁尸。
And then after the letter reached Scotland Yard, in the early hours of the 30th of September, the killer struck again, not once, but twice the so-called double event. You know, one of the most dramatic nights in the history of London. and then we come to the most horrific murder of all, which was on the 9th of November, wasn't it?
在信件到达苏格兰场后，9月30日凌晨，凶手再次作案，不是一次，而是两次，即所谓的“双重事件”。你知道，这是伦敦历史上最戏剧性的夜晚之一。然后我们来到了最恐怖的谋杀案，发生在11月9日，不是吗？
Yes, and that was, again, a woman eviscerated, but this time not on the streets as the other victims of the Whitechapel murderer had been, but in a cramped and mean room in a place called Miller's Court, in the dark heart of White Chapel. and to those who saw that victim, it seemed even compared to the previous victims, a vision of hell. So one of the witnesses was a woman who had lived above the victim, so directly above the murder scene, and she said, I could bear to look at it only for a second, but I can never forget the sight of it if I live to be 100. And another, the man who had forced the locked door of the victim's room, he said, the sight we saw.
是的，那又是一名被剖腹的女性，但这次不是像白教堂凶手的其他受害者那样在街上，而是在白教堂黑暗中心一个叫米勒庭院（Miller's Court）的地方，一间狭窄而简陋的房间里。对于那些看到受害者的人来说，即使与之前的受害者相比，那也是地狱般的景象。其中一位目击者是一位住在受害者楼上的女性，也就是直接住在案发现场楼上，她说：“我只能看一眼，但我活到100岁也忘不了那景象。”另一位是强行打开受害者房门的人，他说：“我们看到的景象，
I cannot drive away from my mind. It looked more like the work of a devil than of a man. But as it turns out almost certainly, although maybe not, but almost certainly, the horror of that murder, the horror of Miller's court, seems to have been the climax of Jack the Ripper's reign of terror. And the thing that people found eerie about that reign of terror wasn't just the brutality, but the ability of the murderer always to be one step ahead of the police, to avoid apprehension, to avoid almost being seen.
我无法从脑海中抹去。那看起来更像是魔鬼的工作，而不是人的所为。”但事实证明，几乎可以肯定，尽管也许不一定，但几乎可以肯定，那场谋杀的恐怖，米勒庭院的恐怖，似乎是开膛手杰克恐怖统治的高潮。人们对那段恐怖统治感到毛骨悚然的，不仅仅是残暴，而是凶手总能领先警察一步，逃避逮捕，甚至几乎不被发现。
And now with this terrible murder in Miller's court, he kind of banishes as though into thin air, and he leaves behind him what I think is undoubtedly the most enduring mystery in the annals of crime, would you agree? Definitely. He's the one serial killer whose name is known across the world who appears in films and video games as we shall talk about
现在，随着米勒庭院这起可怕的谋杀案，他仿佛凭空消失了，留下了我认为无疑是犯罪史上最持久的谜团，你同意吗？当然。他是全世界都知道的连环杀手，正如我们将要谈到的那样，他出现在电影和电子游戏中，
and novels and all sorts of things. And I guess even at the time there was something otherworldly about him, wasn't there, to people in London. So people would describe him right from an early stage. This isn't sort of back projection.
以及小说和各种各样的作品中。我想即使在当时，对于伦敦人来说，他身上也有某种超自然的东西，不是吗？所以人们从很早就开始描述他。这并不是什么事后投射。
People would talk about him as a ghost slipping through the streets of the East End, as a ghoul or a vampire kind of feeding on the blood. Yeah, they literally use the word vampire. Yes, exactly. So there's a quote, isn't there, from the East London advertiser. What can be more appalling than the thought that there's a being in human shape,
人们谈论他就像一个在东区街道上穿行的幽灵，像一个以鲜血为食的食尸鬼或吸血鬼。是的，他们确实用了“吸血鬼”这个词。是的，没错。所以，《东伦敦广告报》上有一段引文，不是吗？还有什么比想到有一个人形生物，
stealthily moving about a great city, burning with a thirst for human blood, and endowed with such diabolical astuteness as to enable him to gratify his fiendish lust with absolute impunity. And it's the sort of combination of the horror... but also the stealth, that he is, I mean, especially the night when he kills two people, that he is moving from one scene to another, like a wraith in the night, you know, completely undetected. He must know the area like the back of his hand. He's always one step ahead of the police.
在伟大的城市中潜行，燃烧着对人血的渴望，并拥有如此邪恶的精明，使他能够绝对逍遥法外地满足他那魔鬼般的欲望，更令人震惊的呢？这种恐怖与潜行的结合，我的意思是，特别是在他杀害两个人的那个晚上，他像黑夜中的幽灵一样从一个现场移动到另一个现场，你知道，完全没有被发现。他一定对那个地区了如指掌。他总是领先警察一步。
And for people at the time, that was both horrifying, but also kind of darkly fascinating, wasn't it? I mean, in that the thirst for human blood, I mean, there's something vampiric, but there's also a kind of a hint of almost cannibalism because organs. are being excised and there are rumors that they're being eaten by the killer. So it does seem something very primordial. But at the same time, there is a feeling that this is something perhaps expressive of modernity. So there's another newspaper that says of Jack the Ripper, and perhaps he is some mysterious and awful product of modern civilization. So people are
对于当时的人们来说，这既令人恐惧，又有一种黑暗的吸引力，不是吗？我的意思是，那种对人血的渴望，有一种吸血鬼的特质，但也有某种暗示，几乎是食人，因为器官被切除了，而且有传言说凶手吃了它们。所以这看起来确实非常原始。但与此同时，人们也感觉到这或许是现代性的表现。所以还有另一份报纸谈到开膛手杰克时说，也许他是现代文明某种神秘而可怕的产物。所以人们在
wondering, what is it about our industrial society that is producing such a monster? And we've said that Jack the Ripper is the most famous serial killer. I think almost the most intriguing thing about him from the historical point of view is he's actually the first serial killer we know about. I mean, presumably there were serial killers before him, but he is the first person who is identified as a serial killer in the sense that we understand it today in 2025. Yeah, there were people previously who'd killed an awful lot of people, so in middle ages or whatever, but there was not the sense of a serial killer phenomenon. And he invents
想，我们的工业社会究竟是什么造就了这样一个怪物？我们说过开膛手杰克是最著名的连环杀手。我认为从历史角度来看，关于他最引人入胜的一点是，他实际上是我们所知的第一个连环杀手。我的意思是，大概在他之前也有连环杀手，但他是在我们今天2025年所理解的意义上，第一个被认定为连环杀手的人。是的，以前也有杀过很多人的人，比如在中世纪什么的，但没有“连环杀手”这种现象的概念。而他发明了
the phenomenon, doesn't he? Or rather, the newspaper editors who write about him invent the phenomenon. Or the psychiatrists who kind of home in on what he represents as a particular kind of monster. And they classify what he might be in scientific terms. And I think that's also a part of the story. So for all these reasons, he's notorious, but I think there are two obvious reasons why he remains such a notorious figure still, almost 150 years on. The first most obvious is that he was never caught. So his identity remains a mystery to this day. And we will be exploring the range of possible suspects in our final episode of this five-part series. Surely solving the mystery and unveiling the killer. We will. But also, I think that
这种现象，不是吗？或者更确切地说，报道他的报纸编辑们发明了这种现象。或者那些专注于他所代表的特定怪物类型的精神病学家。他们用科学术语对他的身份进行了分类。我认为这也是故事的一部分。所以由于所有这些原因，他臭名昭著，但我认为他之所以在近150年后仍然是一个如此臭名昭著的人物，有两个显而易见的原因。第一个最明显的原因是他从未被抓获。所以他的身份至今仍是一个谜。我们将在本五集系列的最后一集中探讨各种可能的嫌疑人。一定会解开这个谜团并揭开凶手的面纱。我们会。但我也认为，
name, Jack the Ripper. I mean, it's so horribly, brilliantly memorable. We will be returning to that letter and other letters that were thought by the police at the time, perhaps to have been sent by the murderer, asking whether they really were, were they authentic or were they fakes. There are lots to come. Yeah, absolutely. So we've got lots of episodes to come. But just on this sort of history of the study of Jack the Ripper. So Jack the Ripper was a literary phenomenon right from the beginning as much as he was a kind of a physical one, because most people experienced the Ripper story through the newspapers. And ever since, you know, people have written about him.
“开膛手杰克”这个名字。我的意思是，它太可怕、太精彩、太令人难忘了。我们将回到那封信以及当时警察认为可能是凶手寄出的其他信件，询问它们是否真的是真实的，还是伪造的。还有很多内容要讲。是的，绝对。所以我们还有很多集要讲。但就关于开膛手杰克的研究历史而言。开膛手杰克从一开始就是一个文学现象，就像他是一个现实中的人物一样，因为大多数人是通过报纸了解开膛手故事的。从那以后，你知道，人们一直在写关于他的文章。
They've never stopped writing about him. So there's an Australian journalist in 1929, isn't they, called Leonard Matters, who wrote one of the first big studies of the murders. And he said, if a journalist cannot sell anything else in London, he can always sell a story about Jack the Ripper. And it's interesting he's Australian, because it's a reminder that Jack the Ripper is properly a global story. people are fascinated by this and you know huge topic of fascination in the english speaking world but
他们从未停止过写他。所以1929年有一位澳大利亚记者，叫伦纳德·马特斯（Leonard Matters），他写了关于这些谋杀案的第一批大型研究之一。他说，如果一个记者在伦敦卖不出别的东西，他总能卖出关于开膛手杰克的故事。他是个澳大利亚人这一点很有趣，因为它提醒我们，开膛手杰克确实是一个全球性的故事。人们对此非常着迷，你知道，这是英语世界中一个巨大的迷人话题，但
even beyond the english speaking world as well and to this day the idea that if you want to sell a book you come up with a theory about who jack the ripper was i mean it remains the case and there's this entire field ripperology it's a kind of subgenre of the true crime genre and i guess that we by doing this um this podcast are you know we're standing in that tradition aren't we So not only did I read lots of books about this, but there's a website called Casebook, Jack the Ripper, and it's the world's largest repository of a Ripper Rihanna. And when you fall into that hole, there is always a danger that you will never, ever climb out again. There were moments researching this where I just thought, I'm absolutely drowning in kind of theories and stuff here. Yeah, it's not another kidney.
甚至在英语世界之外也是如此。直到今天，如果你想卖出一本书，你就会提出一个关于开膛手杰克是谁的理论，这种情况依然存在。而且有一个完整的领域叫“开膛手学”（Ripperology），它是真实犯罪类型的一个子流派。我想我们通过制作这个播客，你知道，我们正处于那个传统之中，不是吗？所以，我不仅读了很多关于这个的书，还有一个叫“案例书：开膛手杰克”（Casebook, Jack the Ripper）的网站，它是世界上关于开膛手研究资料最大的存储库。当你掉进那个洞里时，总有一种危险，那就是你永远、永远也爬不出来。在研究这个的时候，有几次我只是觉得，我完全淹没在各种理论和资料中了。是的，不是另一个肾脏。
Exactly. Right. Not quite, but yeah. But the thing about Jack the Ripper, so for those people who are thinking, hold on, this isn't the rest is true crime. The Jack the Ripper story is a brilliant window onto 1880s London, isn't it? I mean, that's the appeal of it. It's a fascinating melodrama in its own right, but it also allows us to do all kinds of social and cultural and political history of a period
没错。差不多，但确实。但关于开膛手杰克的事情是，对于那些认为“等等，这不是‘历史即真实犯罪’”的人来说，开膛手杰克的故事是了解1880年代伦敦的一扇绝佳窗口，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是它的吸引力所在。它本身就是一部引人入胜的通俗剧，但它也让我们能够进行那个时期各种社会、文化和政治历史的研究，
that looms quite large in our collective imagination because of, as we'll see, Dr. Jackly and Mr. Hyde and Sherlock Holmes and the sort of the image of the Dracula, the image of the gas lamps and the fog and the streets of London. And so on London, at this imperial height, and that's another element to this story. So that's the appeal of this for us, isn't it, as historians? Well, I think it reminds me of the series we did on Titanic, which was like this, a drama replete with horror and with tragedy and has essentially become a myth, again,
那个时期在我们的集体想象中占据了很大的位置，因为正如我们将要看到的，《化身博士》（Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde）、《福尔摩斯》（Sherlock Holmes），以及那种德古拉的形象、煤气灯、雾气和伦敦街道的形象等等。伦敦处于帝国鼎盛时期，这也是这个故事的另一个要素。所以这就是它对我们作为历史学家的吸引力，不是吗？嗯，我想这让我想起了我们做的关于泰坦尼克号的系列，它就像这样，是一部充满恐怖和悲剧的戏剧，本质上已经成为一个神话，再次，
something that everybody knows about. But it does simultaneously provide a brilliant window onto the social history of the age. So if you look at that letter, the famous Jack the Ripper letter with which we opened this episode, you've got hints of all kinds of aspects of late Victorian life that we will be talking about in this series. So there's the police, you know, Jack the Ripper is mocking them for being useless. You've got the press. That letter gets sent to a press agency first. To what extent are they creating the image of the Ripper?
每个人都知道的事情。但它同时也提供了一扇了解那个时代社会历史的绝佳窗口。如果你看看那封信，我们开篇提到的那封著名的开膛手杰克信件，你会发现其中暗示了维多利亚时代晚期生活的方方面面，我们将在本系列中讨论这些。有警察，你知道，开膛手杰克嘲笑他们毫无用处。有媒体。那封信首先被寄给了一家新闻机构。他们在多大程度上塑造了开膛手的形象？
The hints of immigration, because leather apron that Jack the Ripper mentioned, he was a Polish Jew who'd been an early suspect. And then there's that kind of final mocking payoff. They say, I'm a doctor now, which is expressive of all kinds of anxieties about medicine, about vivisection, about abortionists, as we'll see. And there's an abiding question that runs throughout the inquests, and which is still a very live issue today among people who study the murders, as to whether the mutilations that the Ripper inflicted on his victims betrayed specialist knowledge. And there's been no consensus about that. But it matters because in Whitechapel, you have the London Hospital. So full of surgeons, full of people who are very proficient with a knife.
关于移民的暗示，因为开膛手杰克提到的“皮围裙”，他是一个波兰犹太人，是早期的嫌疑人。然后是那种最后的嘲弄式结尾。他们说，“我现在是个医生”，这表达了对医学、活体解剖、堕胎者等各种焦虑，正如我们将要看到的。在整个调查过程中，有一个挥之不去的疑问，至今在研究这些谋杀案的人中仍然是一个非常现实的问题，那就是开膛手对受害者造成的毁尸是否暴露了专业知识。对此一直没有达成共识。但这很重要，因为在白教堂，有伦敦医院。所以到处都是外科医生，到处都是用刀非常熟练的人。
But it is also full of knackers' yards and slaughterhouses, of which the barber's horse slaughterhouse was the foulest. So throughout Whitechapel, there are the scent of blood, piles of offal, and of course people walking the streets with aprons, perhaps, you know, spattered with drops of blood. And I think that in that context, the red ink that the ripper, if he is the ripper, is using when he writes that letter, I mean, it's a gruesome kind of knowing joke. It's a hideous, malevolent wink. And I guess the other thing that this has in common with the Titanic story that we did a couple of years ago is that it has the extremes of wealth and poverty, doesn't it?
但它也到处都是动物尸体处理场和屠宰场，其中理发师的马匹屠宰场是最恶臭的。所以整个白教堂都弥漫着血腥味、成堆的内脏，当然还有走在街上的人，也许，你知道，身上溅着血滴。我认为在这种背景下，如果他真的是开膛手，他在写那封信时使用的红墨水，我的意思是，这是一种可怕的、心照不宣的玩笑。这是一个令人毛骨悚然、恶毒的眨眼。我想这与我们几年前做的泰坦尼克号故事的另一个共同点是，它有贫富的极端，不是吗？
privilege and deprivation, the theme of class conflict and class tension runs right through this story. So we'll be spending as much time with the sort of the metropolitan police and the establishment as we will on the streets of Whitechapel. Yeah. So, I mean, it is absolutely a topic of obsessive interest in the corridors of power. And it does seem to people to express something that is rotten in the state of policing and the home office and so on. So the chief Commissioner of the Metropolitan Police, the London Police Force, the guy called Sir Charles Warren, who was originally a military man, served in South Africa. He ends up resigning. And although that is not directly because of the failure of the police to catch the Ripper, the Ripper case is definitely
特权与匮乏，阶级冲突和阶级紧张的主题贯穿了这个故事。所以我们将花同样多的时间在伦敦警察厅和当权派身上，就像我们在白教堂街道上所做的那样。是的。所以，我的意思是，这绝对是权力走廊中令人痴迷的话题。而且它似乎向人们表达了警察系统、内政部等方面存在腐烂的东西。所以伦敦警察厅的首席专员，伦敦警察部队，一个叫查尔斯·沃伦爵士（Sir Charles Warren）的人，他最初是一名军人，曾在南非服役。他最终辞职了。尽管这并非直接因为警察未能抓住开膛手，但开膛手案件绝对是
a contributory factor to that resignation. You've got a Tory government, Home Secretary, Henry Matthews, he comes close to following Sir Charles Warren. And even the Prime Minister, Lord Salisbury, By the end of the case, he's getting kind of irate telegrams from Queen Victoria. So the day after the climactically hideous murder at Miller's court, she telegraphs him. This new ghastly murder shows the absolute necessity for some very decided action. All these courts must be lit and our detectives improved. They are not what they should be.
导致辞职的一个促成因素。你有一个保守党政府，内政大臣亨利·马修斯（Henry Matthews），他差点跟随查尔斯·沃伦爵士而去。甚至首相索尔兹伯里勋爵（Lord Salisbury），到案件结束时，他收到了来自维多利亚女王愤怒的电报。所以在米勒庭院那场极其恐怖的谋杀案发生后的第二天，她给他发了电报：“这起新的可怕谋杀案表明，绝对有必要采取一些非常果断的行动。所有这些庭院都必须照明，我们的侦探必须改进。他们不是他们应该有的样子。”
So Queen Victoria there sounding eerily like Mrs. Thatcher. Yeah. And yet on the other hand, I mean, the place we'll be spending most of our time, It's probably the single grimmest place in London, arguably, you know, one of the grimmest places in certainly in England, if not in Britain. And this is Whitechap of the East End. It's centered on Spittal Fields. It is really important for listeners to get this into their heads. It is not like it is now.
所以维多利亚女王听起来简直就像撒切尔夫人。是的。然而另一方面，我的意思是，我们将花费大部分时间的地方，可能是伦敦最阴森的地方，可以说，（当然是在英国，如果不是在不列颠的话）最阴森的地方之一。这就是东区的白教堂。它以斯皮塔佛德（Spitalfields）为中心。让听众把这一点记在脑子里非常重要。它不像现在这样。
It is an absolute kind of reeking, stinking, crowded, labyrinth of little, a sort of warren of little alleys and courts, lines with these kind of crumbling, decrepit tenement. houses and Doss houses and lodging houses. And the very names of the streets, to people at the time reading this in the newspaper, so Flower and Dean Street, Dorset Street, Thrill Street, Blood Alley, frying pan alley, shovel alley. These places, these were redolence of extreme poverty, you know, the sort of poverty that you would not associate with the richest and most, you know, powerful country on earth. They're the last what were called rookeries in the Keynesian period in the 18th century.
它是一个绝对的、散发着恶臭、拥挤、迷宫般的小巷和庭院，一种小巷和庭院的“沃伦”，排列着这些摇摇欲坠、破旧不堪的公寓楼、廉价旅馆和寄宿处。街道的名字，对于当时在报纸上读到这些的人来说，比如花与迪恩街（Flower and Dean Street）、多塞特街（Dorset Street）、瑟尔街（Thrill Street）、血巷（Blood Alley）、煎锅巷（Frying Pan Alley）、铲子巷（Shovel Alley）。这些地方，它们是极端贫困的代名词，你知道，那种你不会与地球上最富有、最强大的国家联系在一起的贫困。它们是18世纪凯恩斯时期所谓的最后的一批“鸟巢”（rookeries）。
They, you know, they're kind of tangles of streets that are seen as being literally poisonous, full of sewage and rubbish and vermin, and also incredibly violent. And so whether it's true or not is debated, but the kind of, you know, the conventional take is that the police only enter this area in pairs. And to readers of newspapers in the West End, it's a synonym for. violence. So here is the Daily Telegraph. In these squalid parts of the metropolis, aggravated assaults tended by flesh wounds from knives are frequently met with, and men and women become accustomed to scenes of violence. And I think that is fundamentally true, because it is a centre of street crime and of prostitution. And if you end up there, then you know that you have pretty much plumbed the bottom. So to quote Jerry White in his great study of London in the
它们，你知道，它们是那种被视为字面上是有毒的、充满污水、垃圾和害虫的街道纠缠，而且极其暴力。所以无论这是真是假，人们都在争论，但那种（你知道，传统的看法是）警察只有成对进入这个地区。对于西区的报纸读者来说，它是暴力的同义词。所以这是《每日电讯报》的报道：“在大都市这些肮脏的地区，由刀具造成的肉体创伤引起的严重袭击经常发生，男人和女人已经习惯了暴力场面。”我认为这是根本真实的，因为它是街头犯罪和卖淫的中心。如果你最终到了那里，那么你就知道你已经几乎触底了。所以引用杰里·怀特（Jerry White）在他关于19世纪伦敦的伟大研究中的话，
19th century, successful thieves, like successful prostitutes, did not stay in Flarendine Street. And Flarendine Street is the kind of the epitome of the horrors of Spittal Fields, if only because they would not long remain immune from the depredations of their fellows. However, having said that, it is important to emphasize that not everyone who is living in Spittlefields by any means is a career criminal or a career prostitute. Lots of people are there because they have nowhere else to go because they are absolutely at the bottom. So this brings us to Jack the Ripper's victims who will be playing a very big part in this story.
“成功的窃贼，就像成功的妓女一样，不会待在花与迪恩街。”而花与迪恩街是斯皮塔佛德恐怖的缩影，仅仅因为他们不会长期免受同伙的掠夺。然而，话虽如此，必须强调的是，并不是所有住在斯皮塔佛德的人都是职业罪犯或职业妓女。很多人在那里是因为他们无处可去，因为他们绝对处于底层。所以这就把我们带到了开膛手杰克的受害者身上，她们将在本故事中扮演非常重要的角色。
And right from the start, there was a sense that the Victorian reading public, the people who are the first consumers of the Jack the Ripper melodrama, are much more interested in Jack the Ripper than they are in his victims. And actually, I guess, a telling sign of this, you know, we're complicit in this as well so far because we haven't actually named any of the victims. a lot about Jack and of the context, but we haven't named, you know, Polly Nichols or Catherine Eddows or Annie Chapman or whatever. And that's something that we will be trying to remedy in this series
从一开始，人们就感觉到维多利亚时代的阅读公众，那些作为开膛手杰克通俗剧第一批消费者的人，对开膛手杰克比对他的受害者更感兴趣。实际上，我想，一个说明这一点迹象是，（你知道，到目前为止我们在这方面也是同谋，因为我们实际上还没有提到任何受害者的名字）。关于杰克和背景谈了很多，但我们没有提到，你知道，波莉·尼科尔斯（Polly Nichols）或凯瑟琳·埃多斯（Catherine Eddowes）或安妮·查普曼（Annie Chapman）等等。这是我们在这个系列中将要尝试补救的事情，
because we'll also have a special bonus episode for our club members. I'm looking in more depth of three of the victims and their lives and what they tell us about the world of late Victorian England. And actually, Hallie Rubenhold, who's been on the show in the early days, she wrote a book called The Five, didn't she, in 2019, a prize-winning book, which was a sort of group biography of the murdered women. And as she, you know, pointed out, you know, people wouldn't write books about their stories, were it not for the way in which it ended?
因为我们还将为我们的俱乐部成员提供一集特别的奖励节目。我将更深入地研究其中三名受害者及其生活，以及她们告诉我们关于维多利亚时代晚期世界的信息。实际上，哈莉·鲁本霍尔德（Hallie Rubenhold），她在早期节目中来过，她写了一本叫《五人》（The Five）的书，不是吗，在2019年，一本获奖书籍，这是一部关于被谋杀女性的集体传记。正如她（你知道，指出的那样），如果不是因为结局的方式，人们不会写关于她们故事的书？
It's this kind of horror of their deaths that has made them, you know, if you reel off the names of the victims, a lot of people will recognize them, but they won't know much about the victims. And probably what they do know may well be wrong, because people tended to see them purely as prostitutes rather than as human beings with kind of backgrounds and inner lives of their own. Yeah, I mean, that's why Halley's book was so revelatory and why it was deservedly prize-winning. But, I mean, as she acknowledges, they are only remembered because they all shared the same terrible fate. So she wrote the courses their lives took, mirrored that of so many other women of the Victorian age, and yet we're so singular in the way they ended. And again, I think that is another comparison with Titanic, that it's the horror of their deaths that enable them to serve us as exemplars of,
正是这种死亡的恐怖使她们成为了（你知道，如果你列举受害者的名字，很多人会认出她们，但他们对受害者了解不多）。而且他们所知道的可能很可能是错误的，因为人们倾向于仅仅把她们看作妓女，而不是有背景和内心生活的普通人。是的，我的意思是，这就是为什么哈莉的书如此具有启发性，为什么它当之无愧地获奖。但是，我的意思是，正如她所承认的，她们之所以被记住，只是因为她们都分享了同样的悲惨命运。所以她写道，她们的生活轨迹反映了维多利亚时代许多其他女性的生活，然而她们的结局却是如此独特。再次，我认为这是与我们几年前做的泰坦尼克号的另一个比较，即她们死亡的恐怖使她们能够作为我们社会中一个通常不会进入历史书的阶层的典范。
a class of society that normally doesn't enter the history books. And the class of person who is being killed by Jack the Ripper, they are even more lost to poverty than those who are traveling in the steerage of Titanic. They are indigent. They are absolutely the bottom and they are women. And it does give us an opportunity to kind of focus on the lives of people who, as I say, don't normally feature in our podcasts. But when the Victorian are reading about these women's lives. I mean, they're not terribly interested, I think, in the personal stories of the women, but they are interested in the background, aren't they, in the East End, more generally. I said they're obsessed by it, actually. Yeah, because I guess
而被开膛手杰克杀害的那类人，她们比那些在泰坦尼克号三等舱旅行的人更贫困。她们是赤贫者。她们绝对处于底层，而且她们是女性。这确实给了我们一个机会，去关注那些（正如我所说）通常不会出现在我们播客中的人们的生活。但当维多利亚时代的人阅读这些女性的生活时。我的意思是，我认为他们对这些女性的个人故事并不太感兴趣，但他们对背景感兴趣，不是吗，对东区，更广泛地说。我说他们实际上对此着迷。是的，因为我想
there's an excitement and a sort of weird glamour about somewhere that is, that's fallen so far from the standards of Victorian morality and Victorian prosperity. Well, there's Whitechapel High street, which the slums kind of go off Whitechapel High Street. But that street is the entertainment capital of working class London. So it's full of taverns and music halls. And for people who kind of want to plunge into the back alleys, there's always the prospect of kind of illicit sex there. So it does attract people from across the East End, but also people from the West End as well, who want to go slumming because what's dangerous is also exciting. And so the sight of young blood, going up east. You know, it is a common sight in Whitechapel, but it's not just, you know,
对于一个已经远远背离维多利亚时代道德和维多利亚时代繁荣标准的地方，有一种兴奋感和一种奇怪的魅力。嗯，有白教堂大街（Whitechapel High Street），贫民窟从白教堂大街延伸出去。但那条街是工人阶级伦敦的娱乐之都。所以它到处都是酒馆和音乐厅。对于那些（你知道，想要潜入后巷的人）来说，那里总是有非法性交易的前景。所以它确实吸引了来自整个东区的人，但也吸引了来自西区的人，他们想去“贫民窟旅游”（slumming），因为危险的东西也令人兴奋。所以看到年轻的贵族，向东走。你知道，这在白教堂是一个常见的景象，但不仅仅是，你知道，
rakes and ruways who are to be seen in Whitechapel and kind of touring the warrens of Flarendine Street and Thrill Street and so on. There are also, of course, humanitarians and moralists. And there is definitely a sense at the end of the Victorian period when Britain is it's imperial apoge, that the East End is the dark shadow, not just of London's greatness as an imperial capital, but of Britain's status as a great power. And it seems to embody something about a megalopolis, an industrial megalopolis, that people find both disturbing and fascinating. I mean, London at this point, I think is indisputably the capital, not just of the British Empire, but of the world. It's the biggest city that's ever existed. Four million people
在白教堂可以看到的浪荡子和流氓，以及游览花与迪恩街和瑟尔街等迷宫的人。当然，还有人道主义者和道德家。在维多利亚时代末期，当英国处于帝国鼎盛时期时，绝对有一种感觉，即东区是黑暗的阴影，不仅是伦敦作为帝国首都的伟大，也是英国作为大国地位的阴影。它似乎体现了关于大都市、工业大都市的一些东西，人们发现这既令人不安又令人着迷。我的意思是，伦敦在这一点上，我认为无可争议地是首都，不仅是大英帝国的首都，而且是世界的首都。它是曾经存在过的最大的城市。四百万人
or so, I think possibly. I think that's actually an underestimate. I think, you know, if you go bigger, greater London, you're looking at more like six million people. I mean, it's a, it's a people at the time, it is a jaw-dropping spectacle. The sprawl and the crowds and the excitement and the modernity of London, because it's the heart of the British Empire. The city of London is there, the kind of financial nerve centre of global capitalism, of shipping, It's still a port. It's a manufacturing city at the time. So there are lots of factories.
左右，我想可能。我认为那实际上是低估了。我想，（你知道，如果你算上大伦敦，你看到的是更接近六百万人）。我的意思是，这是一个，当时的人们，这是一个令人瞠目结舌的奇观。伦敦的扩张、人群、兴奋和现代性，因为它是大英帝国的心脏。伦敦城在那里，全球资本主义、航运的金融神经中枢，它仍然是一个港口。它当时是一个制造业城市。所以有很多工厂。
So it's full of smoke. And the smoke blends with the famous fog, the notorious fog. And I think because of this, you have a sense that what happens in London matters for the entire world. And this is kind of partly propagated by the fact that London, as well as being the center of everything else, is also the center of the world publishing industry. So the newspapers that are printed in London have a reach that perhaps the American, American media today would have globally. But it is also because people come to London from across the world to see what their own future is going to look like. It's a vision of the cities of the future. And so again, there is a sense that what happens in its darkest corners,
所以它到处都是烟雾。烟雾与著名的雾气、臭名昭著的雾气混合在一起。我认为正因为如此，你有一种感觉，即伦敦发生的事情对整个世界都很重要。这在一定程度上是因为伦敦不仅是其他一切的中心，也是世界出版业的中心。所以伦敦印刷的报纸的影响力，也许是今天的美国媒体在全球所拥有的影响力。但这也是因为人们从世界各地来到伦敦，看看他们自己的未来会是什么样子。这是未来城市的愿景。所以再次，有一种感觉，即在它最黑暗的角落里发生的事情，
you know, it has a relevance for everyone pretty much. If you're on the left, if you're a radical or a socialist or whatever, the spectacle of the poverty in London is a reminder of the iniquities of capitalism. But it's also the chance of, you know, a new dawn, isn't it? Because you're hoping that from this darkness, some new light will come, that it will be the breeding ground for revolution and rebellion, right? That's what Karl Marx and co-think. Yeah, and Karl Marx, of course, is a refugee in London, and he is very familiar with the East End. He describes it as a pool of stagnant misery and desolation. But he sees in that pool of stagnant misery and desolation the prospect, as you say, of a brighter future of a revolution.
（你知道，它对每个人几乎都有关联）。如果你在左翼，如果你是一个激进分子或社会主义者什么的，伦敦贫困的景象提醒人们资本主义的不公。但这也是（你知道，新黎明）的机会，不是吗？因为你希望从这种黑暗中，会有一些新的光芒出现，它将成为革命和叛乱的温床，对吧？这就是卡尔·马克思等人所想的。是的，卡尔·马克思当然是伦敦的难民，他非常熟悉东区。他将其描述为“停滞的苦难和荒凉的池塘”。但他从那个停滞的苦难和荒凉的池塘中看到了（正如你所说）革命的美好未来的前景。
utopia. And this, of course, for the vast majority of the Victorian middle classes, is precisely what they most dread, that the misery and the violence that they see as being incubated in places like Thrill Street or Dorset Street or whatever, that this will kind of spread and infect the entire city. The sense of it as a breeding ground for a kind of moral pestilence is a recurrent theme in the press of the Times. So to quote the Times, we have long ago learned that organic refuse breeds pestilence. Can we doubt that neglected human refuse as inevitably breeds crime, that crime reproduces itself like germs in an infected atmosphere and becomes at each successive cultivation more deadly, more bestial, and more absolutely unrestrained. So this
乌托邦。当然，对于绝大多数维多利亚时代的中间阶层来说，这正是他们最恐惧的，即他们在瑟尔街或多塞特街等地看到的苦难和暴力，会扩散并感染整个城市。将其视为某种道德瘟疫的温床是当时媒体的一个反复出现的主题。所以引用《泰晤士报》的话：“我们很久以前就了解到，有机垃圾会滋生瘟疫。我们能否怀疑，被忽视的人类垃圾是否不可避免地滋生犯罪，犯罪像受感染大气中的细菌一样自我复制，并且在每次连续的培养中变得更加致命、更加兽性、更加绝对不受约束。”所以这个
point about crime, I think, is really important because in the 1880s, there's a huge moral panic about crime. There'd been an economic downturn since 1973, since the panic of 1973. So there's a sense that even at its height, Britain, British establishment and opinion is still very jittery. Jerry White, in his book on late 19th century London, he's got a brilliant section about crime. And he says, you know, you might think it's an ordered safe city. But actually, there are dozens of murders every year. There's a gun crime panic. In 1887, so the year before these murders start, there were 18,000 missing people reported in London.
关于犯罪的观点，我认为非常重要，因为在1880年代，人们对犯罪有一种巨大的道德恐慌。自1873年以来，自1873年的恐慌以来，经济一直处于低迷状态。所以有一种感觉，即使在鼎盛时期，英国、英国的当权派和舆论仍然非常紧张。杰里·怀特在他关于19世纪末伦敦的书中，有一段关于犯罪的精彩章节。他说，（你知道，你可能认为这是一个有序、安全的城市）。但实际上，每年都有几十起谋杀案。有一种枪支犯罪恐慌。1887年，也就是这些谋杀案开始的前一年，伦敦报告了18,000名失踪人口。
So it's a place where you can fall through the cracks really quickly. But also, if you're one of the middle class people reading your copy of The Daily Telegraph, you're in a sort of low-level state of anxiety the whole time about precisely what is being bred out there in the East End and, you know, the criminals, the radicals, all of that kind of thing. So 1887 is the year. of Queen Victoria's Golden Jubilee. So, you know, tremendous pomp and circumstance. But in that same year, there had been a massive focus for middle class panic in the place in London that is synonymous with British greatness, namely Trafalgar Square, where Nelson's column stands, because
所以这是一个你可以很快从裂缝中掉下去的地方。而且，如果你是阅读《每日电讯报》的中间阶层人士之一，你一直处于一种低水平的焦虑状态，关于东区究竟在滋生什么，（你知道，罪犯、激进分子，所有这类事情）。所以1887年是维多利亚女王金禧年。所以，（你知道，巨大的排场和仪式）。但在同一年，伦敦那个与英国伟大同义的地方，即纳尔逊纪念柱所在的特拉法加广场（Trafalgar Square），成为了中间阶层恐慌的巨大焦点，因为
it had become a vast squatters camp. So the homeless had moved in and had set up kind of shacks and tense there. And this becomes a focus for middle class indignation. And there is pressure on the police to do something about it. And so on the 8th of November, Sir Charles Warren, the head of the Metropolitan Police, bans all public assemblies from gathering in Trafalgar Square. And on the 13th of November, there are kind of a series of rallies. So they are organized by socialists, by Irish nationalists, Karl Marx's daughter, Eleanor Marx, is a speaker there, and they try to occupy Trafalgar Square and to hold it against the police. But the police are there in mass force. They've been supplemented by the Grenadier Guards, and they succeed in clearing Trafalgar Square.
它已经变成了一个巨大的非法定居者营地。所以无家可归者搬了进去，并在那里搭建了棚屋和帐篷。这成为了中间阶层愤怒的焦点。警察面临采取行动的压力。所以11月8日，伦敦警察厅厅长查尔斯·沃伦爵士禁止所有公众集会在特拉法加广场聚集。11月13日，发生了一系列集会。所以它们是由社会主义者、爱尔兰民族主义者组织的，卡尔·马克思的女儿埃莉诺·马克思（Eleanor Marx）在那里发表演讲，他们试图占领特拉法加广场并对抗警察。但警察在那里有大规模的武力。他们得到了掷弹兵卫队的补充，他们成功地清理了特拉法加广场。
And this is commemorated as Bloody Sunday. In due course, revolutionaries in Russia will kind of see it as one of the examples of how an advanced industrial economy might conceivably be overthrown by a proletarian revolution. It isn't, in this case, however, Trafalgar Square is held for the establishment, and the homeless are cleared out from their camps, and many of them end up heading to the only place, really, where they can hope to find shelter, which is the Warren of streets off Whitechapel High Street. And Whitechapel has been changed, actually by three things. So one of them which will come on to in the next couple of episodes is immigration specifically from the western part of the Tsarist Empire, of the Russian Empire, so Poland
这被纪念为“血腥星期日”。在适当的时候，俄罗斯的革命者会将其视为先进工业经济如何可能被无产阶级革命推翻的例子之一。然而，在这种情况下，特拉法加广场被当权派守住了，无家可归者被从他们的营地中清理出去，他们中的许多人最终前往他们唯一真正希望找到住所的地方，即白教堂大街旁的街道“沃伦”。白教堂实际上已经被三件事改变了。所以其中之一（我们将在接下来的几集中讨论）是专门来自沙皇帝国西部、俄罗斯帝国的移民，即波兰
and Russia itself. And that's particularly Jewish immigration. So that's one thing that's changed Whitechapel. There's also been a lot of slum clearance, hasn't there? So that, people who have been basically decanted from the slums have ended up being pushed into the back alleys and Doss houses of Spittlefields. So in the heart of Whitechapel. The other thing has been an attempt to crack down on brothels. So in 1885, an act to make further provision for the protection of women and girls. And that basically means that people have been kicked out of their establishments. And they too are now sort of been packed into the East End.
和俄罗斯本身。那特别是犹太移民。所以这是改变白教堂的一件事。还有很多贫民窟清理，不是吗？所以，基本上从贫民窟被疏散的人最终被推到了斯皮塔佛德的后巷和廉价旅馆里。所以是在白教堂的心脏地带。另一件事是试图打击妓院。所以1885年，一项为保护妇女和女孩提供进一步规定的法案。这基本上意味着人们被赶出了他们的场所。他们现在也被挤进了东区。
So it's a sort of, it's a powder keg, Tom. It is a powder keg, yes. Well, I mean, kind of this mood of seething desperation, I guess, in the streets, It's even worse than normal. And so when you have people crammed into terrible housing, I suppose it's unsurprising that recorded incidents of crime have been going up throughout 1887 and then into 1888. To the degree that you might think that, you know, another murder wouldn't create any great stir, I mean, that's not entirely true because there is a particularly horrible murder that takes
所以这是一种火药桶，汤姆。这是一个火药桶，是的。嗯，我的意思是，这种街道上沸腾的绝望情绪，我想，甚至比平时更糟。所以当人们挤在可怕的住房里时，我想这并不奇怪，记录在案的犯罪事件在整个1887年以及1888年一直在上升。以至于你可能会认为，（你知道，另一起谋杀案不会引起任何大的轰动，我的意思是，这并不完全正确，因为发生了一起特别可怕的谋杀案）。
place in Whitechapel on the 7th of August 1888. And locals are shocked because it's the body of a woman called Martha Tabram. And this body has been found crumpled on the landing of a block of tenement flats just off Whitechapel High Street. And Martha had been stabbed 39 times. And there's no clue as to who had done it. And the local press covered the case in considerable detail. So they say that Martha had been butchered, that her assailant had displayed a virulent savagery and so on, but the police are unable to have any clues as to who could have done it or why. And so on the 23rd of August, when the coroner formally announced her cause of death, it was described as being willful murder against some person or persons unknown. So they don't know who did it. And that is a verdict that people will be hearing a lot over the weeks and months that are to follow.
发生在1888年8月7日的白教堂区。当地居民感到震惊，因为死者是一位名叫玛莎·塔布拉姆的女性。这具尸体被发现蜷缩在白教堂大街旁的一栋公寓楼的楼梯平台上。玛莎被刺了39刀。目前没有任何线索指向凶手是谁。当地媒体对这起案件进行了相当详细的报道。他们称玛莎被残忍杀害，凶手表现出了极度的凶残等等，但警方无法找到任何关于凶手是谁或作案动机的线索。因此，在8月23日，当验尸官正式宣布她的死因时，将其描述为“被身份不明的一人或多人蓄意谋杀”。所以他们不知道是谁干的。在接下来的几周和几个月里，人们会频繁听到这个结论。
And there's just the odd hint, isn't there, that this could be the beginning of something, particularly if you're in the newspaper industry, that could bear fruit. So the illustrated police news ran six pictures of the Martha Tabram murder on its front page. And the East London Observer ran two columns about the crime, a unique and mysterious crime, it said. Because, of course, as you say, violence is common, but it's unusual to have a case where of such savagery coupled with no clues, right? with no, it's not, it doesn't seem to be leading anywhere. I guess the one thing is that Martha Tabram is not the kind of victim to excite the attention of the press because she's not, I mean, it sounds a
这其中似乎有一种奇怪的暗示，不是吗？这可能是一场风暴的开端，特别是如果你身处报业，这可能会带来“成果”。《插图警察新闻》在其头版刊登了六张关于玛莎·塔布拉姆谋杀案的照片。《东伦敦观察家报》用了两个专栏报道这起罪行，称其为一起“独特而神秘的罪行”。因为正如你所说，暴力事件很常见，但像这样既极其残忍又毫无线索的案件却很少见，对吧？这似乎没有任何进展。我想有一点是，玛莎·塔布拉姆并不是那种能引起媒体关注的受害者，因为她并不是，我的意思是，这听起来很
horrible thing to say, but she's not terribly glamorous. No, so she's 39, but she looked a lot older because she'd had a life on the streets. So one witness diplomatically described her as a woman who would rather have a glass of ale than a cup of tea. So I think she was probably an alcoholic. she seems to have made a living by kind of hawking trinkets that she kind of made or whatever. And perhaps she, you know, when absolutely desperate, she would sell her body for a few pennies, unclear.
难听，但她并不怎么迷人。是的，她39岁，但看起来老得多，因为她过着流浪街头的生活。一位证人委婉地形容她是一个“宁愿喝杯麦芽酒也不愿喝杯茶”的女人。所以我认为她可能酗酒。她似乎靠兜售自己制作的小饰品之类的东西为生。也许，你知道，当绝对绝望的时候，她会为了几个便士出卖自己的身体，这不清楚。
So her fate is hideous, but she is not, as you say, the kind of person who would necessarily be remembered. She lacks the glamour of the kind of victim who would remain in the news. papers for week after week after week. And so it seems like her name will very quickly be forgotten as the weeks pass. But then, Dominic, just one week after the coroner has announced his verdict on her death at her inquest, on the 31st of August, news breaks of another murder. And this is even more terrible.
所以她的命运是可怕的，但正如你所说，她并不是那种会被人们记住的人。她缺乏那种能让受害者在报纸上连续几周占据头条的魅力。因此，随着时间的流逝，她的名字似乎很快就会被遗忘。但是，多米尼克，就在验尸官在死因研讯中宣布她的死因仅一周后，即8月31日，又传出了另一起谋杀案的消息。而这起案件更加可怕。
And it has happened just a short walk from where Martha had been found. And this time, with this murder, people really will sit up and notice. Gosh, well, come back after the break and we will explore the circumstances of this new crime. This episode is brought to you by Aura Frames. History is full of gifts, but the best are those that last. Because photographs have become our modern heirlooms. They're like fragments of the present already turning into history. Aura Frames let you relive these memories every day or give them to someone you love.
它发生的地方离发现玛莎尸体的地方只有很短的步行距离。这一次，随着这起谋杀案的发生，人们真的会坐不住并开始关注了。天哪，好吧，休息之后回来，我们将探讨这起新罪行的具体情况。本集由Aura Frames赞助播出。历史充满了礼物，但最好的礼物是那些能够持久的。因为照片已经成为我们现代的传家宝。它们就像是正在变成历史的当下碎片。Aura Frames让你每天都能重温这些记忆，或者将它们送给你爱的人。
That is our beloved producer Theo, pointing at a kebab in Sarajevo. Preload the photos before it leaves the box, add a message, and you can keep updating it from anywhere. Unlimited storage, no subscription, just memories. For a limited time, visit auraframes.co.com.uk. and get 35 pounds off, Aura's best-selling Carver Matt Frame, named the top frame by the Independent, and use the promo code history at the checkout. That's AuraFra-U-R-A-C-C-O-D-U-K promo code history. This exclusive Black Friday Cyber Monday deal is their best of the year, so order now before it ends.
那是我们敬爱的制片人西奥，指着萨拉热窝的一份烤肉串。在盒子离开之前预装照片，添加一条信息，你就可以从任何地方不断更新它。无限存储，无需订阅，只有回忆。在有限的时间内，访问auraframes.co.uk并获得35英镑的折扣，购买被《独立报》评为最佳相框的Aura最畅销的Carver Matt相框，并在结账时使用促销代码history。那是Aura F-R-A-M-E-S点C-O点U-K，促销代码history。这个独家的黑色星期五和网络星期一优惠是他们全年最好的，所以请在结束前下单。
Support the show by mentioning us at checkout. Terms and conditions apply. This episode is brought to you by Hotels.com. Make your next trip work for you. Hotels.com just rolled out a game-changing feature called Save Your Way, and it's as simple as it sounds. When you book a trip as a Hotels.com member, you decide how to use your savings. Choose to take the instant savings now or to bank the savings as rewards for later. It's your call.
在结账时提到我们以支持本节目。条款和条件适用。本集由Hotels.com赞助播出。让你的下一次旅行物有所值。Hotels.com刚刚推出了一项改变游戏规则的功能，名为“Save Your Way”，听起来很简单。当你作为Hotels.com会员预订旅行时，你可以决定如何使用你的节省金额。选择立即享受即时折扣，或者将节省的金额存为以后的奖励。由你决定。
Invision converting discounts on this week's day into rewards for a luxurious beach getaway next year. No complicated maths, no blackout dates. Just you choosing how to make your travels work harder for you. Only at hotels.com. Save your way is available to loyalty members. in the US and UK on hotels with member prices. Other terms apply. See sight for details. Scarcely has the horror and sensation caused by the discovery of the murdered woman in Whitechapel some short time ago had time to abate than another discovery is made, which for the brutality
想象一下，将本周住宿的折扣转换为明年豪华海滩度假的奖励。没有复杂的数学，没有不适用日期。只有你选择如何让你的旅行更物有所值。仅在Hotels.com。Save Your Way功能适用于美国和英国的忠诚度会员，适用于带有会员价格的酒店。其他条款适用。详情请见网站。白教堂区不久前发现被谋杀女性所引起的恐惧和轰动尚未平息，又有了新的发现，其残忍程度
exercised on the victim is even more shocking and will no doubt create as great assessment sensation in the vicinity as its predecessor. The affair up to the present is enveloped in complete mystery, and the police have as yet no evidence to trace the perpetrators of the horrible deed. So that was the Central News Agency reporting on the 31st of August 1888, the news of what it headlined, A Horrible Murder in Whitechapel. Sir Tom, take us through the story of this.
对受害者施加的手段更加令人震惊，无疑会在附近引起与其前身一样巨大的轰动。到目前为止，这起事件笼罩在完全的神秘之中，警方尚未找到任何线索来追踪这起可怕罪行的肇事者。以上是中央新闻社在1888年8月31日报道的，标题为“白教堂的一起可怕谋杀案”。汤姆爵士，请带我们了解一下这个故事。
new murder. Okay. So the body had been found by a delivery man, car man, as the Victorians call it. And he worked for Pickford's in Covent Garden. And he'd been heading to work from Bethel Green through Whitechapel and he was off to Covent Garden in central London. And he found the body around 3.40 a.m. This was a guy called Charles Lechmere. And he was walking to work down Bucks Row, which is, I mean, it's no longer called Bucks Row, but it's still there. You can still walk down the street, very narrow in Whitechapel. And as he's doing so, he sees this object lying beside the entrance to a stable yard, and it is now one of the entrances to Whitechapel tube station. But at the time, it was what was called a yard crossing, so a kind of narrow alleyway
新的谋杀案。好的。尸体是由一名送货员，维多利亚时代的人称之为“车夫”，发现的。他在科文特花园的皮克福德公司工作。他当时正从贝思纳尔格林经白教堂去上班，目的地是伦敦市中心的科文特花园。他在凌晨3点40分左右发现了尸体。这个人叫查尔斯·莱克米尔。他正走在去上班的路上，经过巴克斯街，我的意思是，它现在不再叫巴克斯街了，但它还在那里。你仍然可以走在那条街上，在白教堂区非常狭窄。当他走的时候，他看到这个物体躺在马厩院子的入口旁边，现在它是白教堂地铁站的入口之一。但在当时，它被称为院子通道，所以是一种狭窄的小巷
leading off the main street into a stable yard. And so he stops, he goes to inspect it, and he finds that it is the body of a woman. And he stands there irresolutely wondering what to do. And as he does so, he's joined by another car man, a guy called Robert Paul, who is also on his way to work. And one of the themes, I think, of this entire series will be the number of people who are either coming back or going to work throughout the night. The streets of Whitechapel are very, very busy. So they both approach the body, which is huddled in the shadows. It's still, you know, It's still nighttime, and they find that the woman is lying on her back. Her skirts have been hitched up over her hips, and Lechmere can't bring himself to touch the body,
通向主街外的一个马厩院子。于是他停下来，去检查一下，发现那是一具女人的尸体。他站在那里犹豫不决，不知道该怎么办。就在这时，另一位车夫，一个叫罗伯特·保罗的人加入了进来，他也是去上班的路上。我认为，整个系列的主题之一将是整晚往返工作的人数之多。白教堂的街道非常非常繁忙。所以他们都走近蜷缩在阴影中的尸体。当时还是，你知道，还是深夜，他们发现女人仰面躺着。她的裙子被撩到了臀部以上，莱克米尔无法让自己去触碰尸体，
but Robert Paul does, and he finds that her skin is cold to the touch. But he presses his ear to her mouth, and he fancies that he can hear her breathing. Now, both men are late for work, so they smooth down the woman's skirts, and they head on their way, and a short distance on, they run into a policeman, and they tell him what they're they've found. And Lechmere says, she looks to me to be either dead or drunk, but for my part, I think she is dead. And so she is. She is very, very dead. And they haven't noticed the details. I guess because what times did you say it was? It's 3.40 in the morning. So dawn is not yet broken. So it's dark. But when the police arrive and they do notice the details. And the details
但罗伯特·保罗碰了，他发现她的皮肤摸起来很冷。但他把耳朵贴在她的嘴边，他觉得能听到她的呼吸声。现在，两人上班都迟到了，所以他们拉平了女人的裙子，继续赶路，走了一小段路后，他们遇到了一个警察，并告诉了他他们发现的情况。莱克米尔说：“在我看来，她要么死了，要么喝醉了，但就我而言，我认为她死了。”确实如此。她已经死得透透的了。他们没有注意到细节。我想是因为你说的什么时间？是凌晨3点40分。所以黎明还没有到来。所以天很黑。但当警察到达时，他们确实注意到了细节。而这些细节
which are rehearsed at the inquest are, as they will be throughout this series, I mean, no surprise. They are really gruesome and really, really, really shocking, aren't they? They are. So listeners should be warned. So the victim's throat had been cut almost from ear to ear. The abdomen had been savagely ripped open, exposing the intestines. The lining of the woman's stomach had been cut in several places. There were also, and I quote the details of the inquest, two small stabs on private parts,
在死因研讯中被反复提及，正如它们在这个系列中一样，我的意思是，并不奇怪。它们真的很可怕，而且非常非常令人震惊，不是吗？确实如此。所以听众应该被警告。受害者的喉咙几乎被从一只耳朵割到了另一只耳朵。腹部被残忍地剖开，露出了肠子。女人的胃内壁在几个地方被割开。还有，我引用死因研讯的细节，私处有两个小刺伤，
apparently done with a strong bladed knife. And the surgeon who conducted the autopsy, a doctor called research. Lou Ellen, he said, he confessed himself to be appalled by what he had been examining. I have seen many terrible cases, but never such a brutal affair as this. Yeah, and I think that's important to bring across right from the beginning. I mean, we don't want to wallow in the details of these crimes, but it is important to convey how horrific they are, to explain what the public reaction is. You know, these are not murders like any other.
显然是用一把强力刀刃造成的。进行尸检的外科医生，一位名叫卢埃林的医生，他说，他承认自己对所检查的情况感到震惊。“我见过许多可怕的案件，但从未见过如此残忍的事件。”是的，我认为从一开始就传达这一点很重要。我的意思是，我们不想沉溺于这些罪行的细节，但传达它们有多么可怕，以解释公众的反应是很重要的。你知道，这些谋杀案与众不同。
I mean, there are stabbings are not uncommon in London in the 1880s. You know, there are dozens every year of people stab to death. But there is something uniquely savage and bestial about Jack the Ripper's murders. Literally visceral. Yeah, visceral, exactly. So the obvious questions are, you know, why would you do such a thing? Who could do it? And actually, who's the woman?
我的意思是，在1880年代的伦敦，刺伤并不罕见。你知道，每年都有几十人被刺死。但开膛手杰克的谋杀案中有一种独特的野蛮和兽性。简直是发自肺腑的。是的，发自肺腑的，没错。所以显而易见的问题是，你知道，为什么要这样做？谁能做到？实际上，这个女人是谁？
Like, who is the victim? Because it's very hard for them to identify who the victims are. So to start with the killer, they are completely bewildered right from the beginning. Like, why would anyone do this in such a savage and bestial way? And also the fact that it's been done in streets down which people could be walking at any moment. Well, we talked about the sense of the killer being a ghoul or a phantom or a specter. And there is from the beginning something strange about his ability to inflict these terrible murders in a public place, even though it is a kind of, you know, a street in the middle of the night.
比如，受害者是谁？因为他们很难确定受害者是谁。所以从凶手开始，他们从一开始就完全困惑了。比如，为什么有人会以如此野蛮和兽性的方式做这件事？而且，这件事是在人们随时可能经过的街道上完成的。嗯，我们谈到了凶手是一个食尸鬼、幻影或幽灵的感觉。从一开始，他能够在公共场所实施这些可怕的谋杀案，尽管这是一种，你知道，深夜的街道，这确实有些奇怪。
So a policeman on his beat, he had walked down Bucks Row half an hour before Lechmere and Paul discovered the body. So that's, well, that's 10 past 3 in the morning. And he hadn't seen anything. And no one had heard anything either. And there was a woman called Mrs. Emma Green, who lived directly above the scene of the murder, who she said she was a light sleeper and had a screen being given she would have heard it, you know, but not a peep. And there were watchmen too nearby. They had heard nothing. So it's evident to the inquest that the murderer must have slit his victim's throat before she'd been able to make a noise.
所以一个巡逻的警察，他在莱克米尔和保罗发现尸体前半小时走过了巴克斯街。所以那是，嗯，那是凌晨3点10分。他什么也没看见。也没有人听到任何声音。有一位名叫艾玛·格林夫人的女士，她直接住在谋杀现场上方，她说她睡眠很浅，如果发生了什么事她肯定会听到的，你知道，但一点动静都没有。附近也有守夜人。他们什么也没听到。所以死因研讯很明显，凶手一定是在受害者发出声音之前就割断了她的喉咙。
So either he'd strangled her or clasped her mouth or whatever. He'd done his terrible work with incredible speed. And then before Lechmere arrives, he must have kind of vanished into presumably the early morning traffic on Whitechapel Road and become part of the crowd. And as you say, he must have been covered with blood. There's an orphan must have been an awful lot of blood. And yet, you know, he hasn't gone, no, no one has spotted him. And that may be because he has a modus operandi that allows him to escape the worst of the blood spattering from the body.
所以要么他勒死了她，要么捂住了她的嘴之类的。他以惊人的速度完成了他可怕的工作。然后，在莱克米尔到达之前，他一定已经消失在白教堂路清晨的交通中，成为了人群的一部分。正如你所说，他身上一定沾满了血。那一定有大量的血。然而，你知道，他没有走，没有，没有人发现他。这可能是因为他有一种作案手法，使他能够逃避身体喷溅出的最严重的血迹。
Or it may be because, as you said at the beginning, there are a lot of slaughterhouses and butcher shops and so on. And a man walking down the street in an apron, you know, in the dark with blood stains will actually go relatively unnoticed. I mean, just on that topic, we're not the rest is true crime, and my knowledge of details of autopsies is not great, but I gather that if someone is strangled and then the throat is cut, there is much less blood. I mean, of course, there is blood, but I gather this as a detail and perhaps people with more medical knowledge than us can confirm that for us. I can't believe you're being so hesitant. Anyway, tell us about the victim. As you say, to begin with, the police are worried it's going to be difficult to, I don't know. identify her. She is examined by Dr. Llewellyn. In his report, he says that she's a woman of small stature, that she's middle-aged, she has graying hair, she has a scar on her forehead, and he specifies one tooth deficient front of upper jaw. But that's nothing unusual. Lots of people in, you know, in Whitechapel have lost a tooth or two. She has very few possessions on her, a comb, a looking
或者可能是因为，正如你在开头所说，那里有很多屠宰场和肉店等等。一个穿着围裙走在街上的人，你知道，在黑暗中带着血迹，实际上会相对不被注意。我的意思是，就这个话题而言，我们其余的是真实犯罪，我对尸检细节的了解并不多，但我认为如果有人被勒死然后喉咙被割开，血会少得多。我的意思是，当然有血，但我认为这是一个细节，也许比我们有更多医学知识的人可以为我们证实这一点。我不敢相信你这么犹豫。总之，告诉我们关于受害者的事。正如你所说，起初，警方担心很难，我不知道。确认她的身份。她由卢埃林医生检查。在他的报告中，他说她是一个身材矮小的女人，她是中年人，她有灰白的头发，她前额有一道伤疤，他特别指出上颌前部缺一颗牙。但这没什么不寻常的。在白教堂，很多人都掉了一两颗牙。她身上几乎没有什么财物，一把梳子，一面镜子，
glass, a handkerchief. None of these give any hint as to her identity. And her clothing, too, is very anonymous. It's shabby. It's stained. The only exception is that she has a new bonnet. Dr. Leland specifies, it's made of black straw and it is trimmed with black velvet. So is that enough to identify her? Well, as it turns out, it is.
一个手帕。这些都没有给出任何关于她身份的暗示。她的衣服也很普通。很破旧。有污渍。唯一的例外是她有一顶新帽子。利兰医生特别指出，它是用黑草编织的，并用黑天鹅绒装饰。那么这足以确认她的身份吗？好吧，事实证明，确实如此。
Because within only a few hours of her body being found, the police have a name, Polly. And their source is an elderly woman called Ellen Holland. So maybe an ancestor, who knows, I don't know. And Ellen had shared a room with Polly in a Doss House on Thrall Street, which is one of the notorious streets in the heart of Spittlefields. So that's one clue. They still don't have a surname, but this will come very shortly because when the police investigate Polly's petticoats, they find that they are stamped with the mark of a workhouse, and to be precise, the workhouse in Lambeth in South London. And they find an inmate of that workhouse who is brought to. inspect Polly's corpse. And this person provides the police with Polly's real name, which is
因为在发现她尸体后的几个小时内，警方就得到了一个名字，波莉。他们的消息来源是一位名叫艾伦·霍兰德的老妇人。所以也许是祖先，谁知道呢，我不知道。艾伦和波莉在斯皮塔佛德中心臭名昭著的街道之一，特拉尔街的一家廉价旅馆里合住一个房间。所以这是一个线索。他们仍然没有姓氏，但这很快就会到来，因为当警方调查波莉的衬裙时，他们发现上面印有济贫院的标记，准确地说是伦敦南部兰贝斯的济贫院。他们找到了该济贫院的一名住户，被带去检查波莉的尸体。这个人向警方提供了波莉的真实姓名，即
Mary Ann Nichols. And the police go and they find that Mary Ann Nichols, Polly has a father who's still alive and she has a husband. And the following day on the 1st of September, Edward Walker, Polly's father and William Nichols, her husband, are brought to inspect her body. And William Nichols, the husband, he gazes down at the corpse of his dead wife, horribly mutilated as it is, and he breaks down, and he has to be comforted by the police inspector. And through his tears, he stammers, I forgive you as you are. I forgive you on account of what you have been to me. I mean, that's a very, it's a very Dickensian scene. And actually, the whole stories that
玛丽·安·尼科尔斯。警方去调查发现，玛丽·安·尼科尔斯，波莉，有一位还活着的父亲，还有一个丈夫。第二天，即9月1日，波莉的父亲爱德华·沃克和她的丈夫威廉·尼科尔斯被带去检查她的尸体。威廉·尼科尔斯，她的丈夫，凝视着他死去的妻子的尸体，尽管它被可怕地毁容了，他崩溃了，不得不由警察督察安慰。他含着泪结结巴巴地说：“我原谅你现在的样子。我原谅你，因为你曾经对我所做的一切。”我的意思是，那是一个非常，这是一个非常狄更斯式的场景。实际上，整个故事
unfolds of Polly Nichols does have a kind of Dickensian arc to it. it, although a Dickensian arc in which, you know, they don't live happily ever after, but the heroine plunges into the abyss and never, ever recovers. Yeah, I think the kind of quality of a Dickens novel hangs over, as you say, completely hangs over her story. So Polly Nichols, let's call her that. She was born in 1845, just off Fleet Street, which today, you know, it's so grand that very few people can afford to live there.
关于波莉·尼科尔斯的故事确实有一种狄更斯式的弧线。虽然是一个狄更斯式的弧线，你知道，他们并没有从此过上幸福的生活，而是女主角坠入深渊，再也没有恢复过来。是的，我认为狄更斯小说的某种特质笼罩着，正如你所说，完全笼罩着她的故事。所以波莉·尼科尔斯，我们就这样称呼她吧。她出生于1845年，就在弗利特街附近，今天，你知道，它太宏伟了，很少有人住得起那里。
Very few people live there at all. But back then, it was, again, a little bit, like Spittlefields in 1888, a kind of warren of alleys and courtyards lined with dilapidated housing, so verging on a rookery. But her parents, I mean, they're poor, but they're certainly not indigent. So her father was a locksmith. Her mother was a laundress. And they belonged to the ranks, I guess, of what Victorians would have called the respectable poor. They have careers. as is very usual in this period, Polly loses a mother early on. So she dies of TB, but Edward Walker continues to provide for his family. And this is very Dickens. Polly steps into her mother's
很少有人住在那里。但在当时，它又有点像1888年的斯皮塔佛德，一种充满小巷和庭院的迷宫，排列着破旧的住房，濒临贫民窟。但她的父母，我的意思是，他们很穷，但肯定不是赤贫。所以她的父亲是一名锁匠。她的母亲是一名洗衣女工。他们属于维多利亚时代人所说的“体面的穷人”阶层。他们有职业。正如这个时期非常普遍的那样，波莉很早就失去了母亲。所以她死于肺结核，但爱德华·沃克继续供养他的家庭。这非常狄更斯。波莉走进了她母亲的
shoes, even though she's still just a young girl, and essentially takes over the maternal role. So looking after her father in the way that little Mel looks after her grandfather or little Dorrit looks after her father. It's kind of very, you know, very reminiscent. of that. And the tone of a morally improving Dickensian melodrama seems to continue when at the age of 18, Polly meets a printer's machinist, because Fleet Street, of course, is the center of the press. And so that's exactly the kind of person that Polly, I hope to meet, someone working for the newspapers. And this is her husband, William Nichols, the guy who comes and sobs over her mutilated corpse in due course. And they move out of
鞋子，尽管她还是个小女孩，基本上接管了母亲的角色。所以像小梅照顾她的祖父或小多丽特照顾她的父亲那样照顾她的父亲。这非常，你知道，非常让人想起那个。而一种道德上提升的狄更斯式情节剧的基调似乎在继续，当18岁时，波莉遇到了一位印刷机操作员，因为弗利特街当然是新闻中心。所以这正是波莉希望遇到的人，一个为报纸工作的人。这就是她的丈夫，威廉·尼科尔斯，那个后来来为她毁容的尸体哭泣的人。他们搬出了
Fleet Street. They moved to Warworth in South London. Polly's father goes with them. They start a family. Polly ends up having five children. And it's a seeming model of domesticity, a mother, a father, a grandfather, children, very kind of like something out of Dickens. So then in 1880, Polly is by now 35. There is a spectacular bust up. And Polly walks out on a husband, out on her five children. One of them is just very, very young, barely an infant. And she never returns. And that's her family broken up. And there's the different accusations, aren't there? And actually, so family breakdown is a theme of almost all the victim's stories, one way or another, the collapse of a relationship. But another theme is alcohol. I mean, in almost all of the cases,
弗利特街。他们搬到了伦敦南部的沃斯沃思。波莉的父亲和他们一起去了。他们开始了一个家庭。波莉最终生了五个孩子。这是一个看似家庭生活的典范，母亲、父亲、祖父、孩子，非常像狄更斯笔下的东西。然后在1880年，波莉当时35岁。发生了一场壮观的决裂。波莉离开了丈夫，离开了她的五个孩子。其中一个非常非常小，几乎还是个婴儿。她再也没有回来。她的家庭破碎了。有不同的指责，不是吗？实际上，家庭破裂是几乎所有受害者故事的主题，以某种方式，关系的崩溃。但另一个主题是酒精。我的意思是，在几乎所有的案件中，
alcohol is a huge factor. And William later claimed that Polly had become an alcoholic, didn't he? And which may well have been true. Holly, it seems that she thought he'd begun an affair with a younger woman who'd been helping with child care. That's right, isn't it? And both those things may have been true, that she was, A, she was drinking and B, he was having an affair. And either way, what we will see again and again with the lives of these women is that something goes horribly wrong and you end up in a spiral. And in this world of late Victorian Britain, you know, no welfare state or not one worthy of the name, once you're in the spiral, it is very, very hard to get out of it and to clamber back. And basically, you know, it's like a game of snakes
酒精是一个巨大的因素。威廉后来声称波莉已经成了酒鬼，不是吗？这很可能是真的。霍莉，似乎她认为他开始与一个帮助照顾孩子的年轻女人有染。那是对的，不是吗？这两件事可能都是真的，她A在喝酒，B他在有外遇。无论哪种方式，我们在这些女性的生活中会一次又一次地看到的是，有些事情出了可怕的错误，你最终陷入了螺旋式下降。在这个维多利亚时代晚期的英国世界里，你知道，没有福利国家，或者没有一个值得称道的福利国家，一旦你陷入螺旋，就非常非常难走出来并爬回去。基本上，你知道，这就像一场蛇
and ladders and you're on a snake that is leading all the way to the bottom, i.e. to Whitechapel. I mean, there is a kind of welfare and anyone who's read Oliver Twist will know what that welfare is because it comes in the form of the workhouse. And if, if, if, if, from this point on, if Polly's story is Dickensian, it's in that Oliver Twist sense. She is plunging into a world of workhouses, of Doss houses, of a kind of desperate struggle on the streets to survive. And she, understandably, to cope with the horrors of this, she turns to drink more and more.
和梯子的游戏，你正处于一条一直通向底部的蛇上，即通向白教堂。我的意思是，有一种福利，任何读过《雾都孤儿》的人都会知道那种福利是什么，因为它以济贫院的形式出现。如果，如果，如果，从这一点开始，如果波莉的故事是狄更斯式的，那是在《雾都孤儿》的意义上。她正坠入一个济贫院、廉价旅馆的世界，在街头为生存而进行的一种绝望的挣扎。为了应对这些恐怖，她理所当然地越来越转向酒精。
And her every attempt to kind of claw her way back up to try and find a solid footing again, kind of found us on the fact that she is. becoming more and more of an alcoholic. And by December 1887, she is homeless and she joins the ranks of the homeless in Trafalgar Square. But she's moved to Trafalgar Square a month after Bloody Sunday. So, you know, when the police had cleared Trafalgar Square. And so the police are in no mood to allow the homeless to reoccupy that public space.
她每一次试图爬回去，试图再次找到立足点的尝试，都因为她越来越酗酒而失败了。到1887年12月，她无家可归，加入了特拉法加广场的无家可归者行列。但她在“血腥星期日”一个月后搬到了特拉法加广场。所以，你知道，当警察清理了特拉法加广场时。所以警察没有心情允许无家可归者重新占据那个公共空间。
And so Polly is one of a number of women who are moved on by the police to a workhouse, and the police are kind of marching through the streets to be processed. But Polly and 10 other women managed to slip away and kind of melt into the side streets. And they return to Trafalgar Square. And there they are formally arrested. And by this point, Polly is drunk. And she's described by the arresting officer as having been the worst woman in the square. And this time they are unable to slip their police escort and Polly and the other 10 women
所以波莉是被警察赶到济贫院的众多女性之一，警察在街上行进以进行处理。但波莉和其他10名女性设法溜走，融入了侧街。她们回到了特拉法加广场。在那里她们被正式逮捕。到这时，波莉已经喝醉了。她被逮捕的警官描述为广场上最糟糕的女人。这一次她们无法摆脱警察的护送，波莉和其他10名女性
all end up back in the workhouse. By now we're into 1888 and Polly makes one last desperate attempt to kind of redeem herself from homelessness and alcoholism. And she is found a placement by the workhouse with a very religious couple in Wonsworth who are called the Cowderys. And it's an expression of their, I guess their kind of their religion that they are willing to take a chance on an alcoholic from the workhouse. as a kind of domestic servant in their house. And they encourage her to write to her father. And this is Polly's first communication with her father for at least a couple of years.
最终都回到了济贫院。现在我们进入了1888年，波莉做出了最后一次绝望的尝试，试图从无家可归和酗酒中救赎自己。济贫院为她找到了一个安置点，与沃斯沃思一对非常虔诚的夫妇在一起，他们叫考德里夫妇。这表达了他们的，我猜是他们某种宗教信仰，他们愿意给济贫院的一个酒鬼一个机会，作为他们家里的家庭佣人。他们鼓励她写信给她的父亲。这是波莉至少两年来第一次与她父亲的交流。
And it sounds like things are okay. So Polly writes, it is a grand place where she's staying with trees and gardens back and front. All has been newly done up. They are teetotalers and very religious. So I ought to get on. So she's got a room and there's no alcohol in the house. So if she was ever going to have a chance,
听起来情况还不错。所以波莉写道，这是一个很棒的地方，她住的地方有树木和花园，前后都有。一切都是新装修的。他们是禁酒主义者，非常虔诚。所以我应该能相处得很好。所以她有了一个房间，房子里没有酒精。所以如果她曾经有过机会，
It's like the bit where Oliver Twist is taken in by the kindly family or whatever. But unfortunately, this isn't a novel. And again, it doesn't work out, right? She doesn't get on with them for some reason. I think she wants drink and there's no drink in the house. And so she abscondes. And Mrs. Cadre wrote to the workhouse, this is how we know about it, saying that Polly had gone and that she had taken clothing with her worth just over three pounds.
这就像《雾都孤儿》被善良的家庭收留的那一段。但不幸的是，这不是小说。而且，它又没成功，对吧？由于某种原因，她和他们相处得不好。我想她想要酒，而房子里没有酒。所以她潜逃了。考德里夫人写信给济贫院，这就是我们知道这件事的原因，说波莉走了，她带走了价值刚超过三英镑的衣服。
And that clothing, presumably, was the clothing that Mrs. Cajdry, had provided to Polly, you know, her kind of work uniforms or dresses or whatever. Which she probably pawned for money for booze, right? Yeah, and probably kept some money, you know, to keep a roof over her head because she ends up in a Doss House on Thrall Street in Spittlefields, and this is Wilmot's lodging house, which was named after a guy called George Wilmot, who'd run it in the 1860s and 70s. And it is, I think, well known on the streets of Spittlefields as a place that accommodates all women. I imagine that the experiences that Polly has been having on the streets would make
那些衣服，大概是考德里夫人提供给波莉的，你知道，她的工作制服或裙子之类的。她可能把它们典当了换钱买酒，对吧？是的，可能还留了一些钱，你知道，为了有栖身之所，因为她最终住进了斯皮塔佛德特拉尔街的一家廉价旅馆，这是威尔莫特的旅馆，以一个叫乔治·威尔莫特的人命名，他在1860年代和70年代经营它。我认为，在斯皮塔佛德的街头，它作为一家容纳所有女性的地方是众所周知的。我想波莉在街上的经历会使
that something that she would really, you know, would be important to her. And so this is where she meets with Ellen Holland, because Ellen Holland is one of three women who is sharing a room in this Doss House with Polly. And sometimes she and Ellen would save money by sharing a bed. And Ellen, you know, she told the police that she'd liked Polly, but unsurprisingly had found her quiet and withdrawn, and to quote Ellen, as if some trouble was weighing upon her mind. And I would guess that there were many, many troubles. Well, those troubles get worse, don't they? Because she runs out of money. She burns through this money. So by the end of August, she's kicked out. Again, this would be a theme of a lot of the Ripper victims. They end up running out of money
那对她来说非常重要。所以这就是她遇到艾伦·霍兰德的地方，因为艾伦·霍兰德是与波莉在这家廉价旅馆合住一个房间的三名女性之一。有时她和艾伦会通过合用一张床来省钱。艾伦，你知道，她告诉警察她喜欢波莉，但不出所料地发现她安静而内向，引用艾伦的话说，“好像有什么烦恼压在她的心头。”我会猜有很多很多的烦恼。嗯，那些烦恼变得更糟了，不是吗？因为她没钱了。她花光了这些钱。所以到八月底，她被赶了出来。同样，这将是许多开膛手受害者故事的主题。她们最终花光了钱
and being kicked out onto the streets. And somehow, you know, we can only speculate how, but there are some obvious possibilities she gets the money for more drink and also she finds a Doss House on Flower and Dean Street, a very grim Doss House. And actually this question of how she gets the money, this is at the heart in many ways
并被赶到街上。不知何故，你知道，我们只能推测如何，但有一些明显的可能性，她得到了买更多酒的钱，而且她还在花和迪恩街找到了一家廉价旅馆，一家非常阴森的廉价旅馆。实际上，关于她如何得到钱的问题，这在很多方面是
of the whole story of Jack the Ripper and his crimes and his victims because the thing that has hung over his victims from the very beginning from the very first reports and from the inquest is the notion that they were all prostitutes, right? Yeah. And so Ellen Holland at the inquest was asked directly if Polly had been a prostitute.
整个开膛手杰克及其罪行和受害者故事的核心，因为从一开始，从最初的报道和死因研讯开始，一直笼罩着他的受害者的事情是她们都是妓女的观念，对吧？是的。所以艾伦·霍兰德在死因研讯中被直接问及波莉是否是妓女。
And she denied it and said she did not think the deceased was leading a fast life. In fact, she seemed very afraid of it. I think there are two things to say about this. The first is that Ellen had really liked Polly and was grief-stricken by her death. And so obviously would have been reluctant to speak ill of her. And the other thing is that Polly clearly clung to memories of her lost respectability. And so she would absolutely have dreaded becoming a fast woman, you know, a prostitute. She clearly preferred to take lodgings away from men.
她否认了，并说她不认为死者过着放荡的生活。事实上，她似乎非常害怕那样。我认为关于这一点有两件事要说。第一是艾伦真的很喜欢波莉，并对她的死感到悲痛。所以显然会不愿说她的坏话。另一件事是波莉显然紧紧抓住她失去的体面的记忆。所以她绝对会害怕成为一个“放荡的女人”，你知道，一个妓女。她显然更喜欢远离男人租房。
So that's why she was in Wilmot's lodging house. But I don't think that any of these things necessarily prove that she was never reduced by desperation to prostitution. And in fact, you might almost say the opposite. And we certainly know that by the standards of the age, she was accounted a prostitute. And this was because one year after walking out on her husband, she'd been recorded in the census as living with another man. And this had enabled William Nicol, her husband, to be legally absolved of the financial responsibilities that up until that point he had had for her. So to quote Christine Corton in her book, London Fog, any female who was kept by a man for however long or shorter period of her life, without benefit of a marriage ceremony, was categorised as a prostitute. And this is why in this period, working class women are always desperate to keep hold of their marriage certificates, because in a sense, it's a testimony to their respectability.
所以这就是为什么她在威尔莫特的旅馆。但我认为这些事情并不一定证明她从未因绝望而沦为妓女。事实上，你几乎可以说相反。我们当然知道，按照那个时代的标准，她被认为是妓女。这是因为在她离开丈夫一年后，她在人口普查中被记录为与另一个男人住在一起。这使得威廉·尼科尔，她的丈夫，能够合法地免除他直到那时为止对她承担的经济责任。所以引用克里斯汀·科顿在她的书《伦敦雾》中的话，任何被男人供养一段时间，无论长短，而没有经过婚姻仪式的女性，都被归类为妓女。这就是为什么在这个时期，工人阶级的女性总是拼命保留她们的结婚证书，因为在某种意义上，这是她们体面的证明。
without it, there is always the risk that they will be labelled a prostitute, even though it's not in the sense that we would use it today, you know, as a professional sex worker. It is a much more embracing term. Yeah, it's a really, really slippery term this. And so I think the only honest answer is it's impossible for us to sort of pin this label definitively on people, even if we wanted to. In his book about London in the 19th century, Jerry White says quite explicitly,
没有它，总有被贴上妓女标签的风险，即使它不是我们今天使用的意义上的，你知道，作为职业性工作者。这是一个更广泛的术语。是的，这是一个非常非常滑头的术语。所以我认为唯一的诚实回答是，我们不可能把这个标签明确地贴在人们身上，即使我们想这样做。杰里·怀特在他关于19世纪伦敦的书里明确指出，
no one knows how many prostitutes that were in London. Estimates varied from 8,000 to 80,000 and sometimes more. All these numbers were clueless, most were influenced by self-interest, even the definition of a prostitute was unclear. It's enlarged by some to include any
没有人知道伦敦有多少妓女。估计从8,000到80,000不等，有时更多。所有这些数字都是毫无根据的，大多数受到自身利益的影响，甚至妓女的定义也不清楚。有些人将其扩大到包括任何
woman living with a man out of wedlock, which is what you've just said. There were few objects of social inquiry that caused more muddle and dishonesty than the prostitute. In other words, it is an immensely amorphous label. The police themselves are actually quite honest about this when they're talking to each other about it. They say, we don't, we don't really know what it means, and we don't really, you know, because we use
与男人未婚同居的女人，这就是你刚才说的。很少有社会调查对象比妓女引起更多的混乱和不诚实。换句话说，这是一个极其模糊的标签。警察自己在谈论这件事时实际上相当诚实。他们说，我们不知道，我们真的不知道这意味着什么，我们真的，你知道，因为我们使用
different definitions. So there are some definitions that are, you're a prostitute if you've been convicted of prostitution. And there are others that are like, no, no, no, you're a prostitute if you're sleeping with men and you're not married. You know, a woman can resort to selling herself once or twice because she's desperate because she's homeless. But it doesn't mean that she's a career prostitute, does it? And Polly Nichols clearly wasn't. So the police have a phrase common prostitute, by which they mean a career prostitute, and it's evident that Polly was not that. But, you know, we just don't know, you know, to what desperate straits was she reduced by her poverty, by her homelessness, by her desperation. And certainly, you know, there would have been
不同的定义。所以有一些定义是，如果你因卖淫被定罪，你就是妓女。还有一些是，不，不，不，如果你和男人睡觉而没有结婚，你就是妓女。你知道，一个女人可能因为绝望因为无家可归而不得不卖身一两次。但这并不意味着她是职业妓女，对吧？波莉·尼科尔斯显然不是。所以警察有一个短语“普通妓女”，他们指的是职业妓女，很明显波莉不是那样的人。但是，你知道，我们只是不知道，你知道，她因贫困、无家可归、绝望而陷入了何种绝望的境地。当然，你知道，白教堂区不会缺少客户，因为那是来自整个东区的劳工、码头工人、屠夫和搬运工习惯去进行性交易的地方。所以总会有机会。我们只是不能说。但我们当然知道，到8月30日，她已经不知何故赚到了足够的钱买她的新帽子，你知道，那顶验尸官描述的用黑草编织并用黑天鹅绒装饰的帽子。
no lack of clients in Whitechapel, because it's where labourers and dockers and slaughtermen and porters from across the whole East End habitually go to sex. So it would always have been an opportunity. We just can't say. But we certainly know that by the 30th of August she had somehow made enough money to buy her new bonnet, you know, the one that fashioned out of black straw and trimmed with black velvet that was described by the coroner.
她那天晚上也有足够的钱在“煎锅”喝得酩酊大醉，那是砖巷和特拉尔街拐角处一家臭名昭著的酒吧。如果你去那里，你仍然可以，它现在是一家中餐馆，但煎锅的形象就在中餐馆上方。所以她在午夜过后半小时离开酒吧，她又身无分文了。所以她去威尔莫特的旅馆试图在那里找个床位，但被拒绝了。她告诉看门人：“我很快就会拿到我的旅馆钱，看看我现在这顶漂亮的帽子。”
And she'd also had enough money to get incredibly drunk that evening in the frying pan, which was a notorious pub on the corner of Brick Lane and Thrill Street. And if you go there, you can still, it's a Chinese restaurant now, but the image of the frying pan is up there above the Chinese restaurant. And so she leaves the pub about half past midnight and she's skint again. And so she goes to Wilmot's lodging house to try and get a bed there and she's turned away. And she tells the doorkeeper, I'll soon get my Doss money, see what a jolly bonnet I've got now.
她又出去了。显然她确实设法以某种方式弄到了一些钱。听众可以，你知道，自己决定她是怎么做到的。但她没有把钱花在床上。相反，她回到“煎锅”喝得更醉了。她在凌晨2点30分前不久离开“煎锅”。她向南朝白教堂路走去。在白教堂路的拐角处，她遇到了艾伦·霍兰德。艾伦·霍兰德记得她当时步履蹒跚，她喝得太醉了，以至于当艾伦拦住她时，波莉瘫倒在墙上。艾伦试图说服她和她一起回威尔莫特旅馆。但波莉说，
And she goes back out. And clearly she does manage somehow to get some money. listeners can, you know, make up their own mind about how she does that. But she doesn't spend it on a bed. Instead, she goes back to the frying pan and gets even more drunk. And she leaves the frying pan shortly before 2.30 a.m. And she heads southwards towards Whitechapel Road. And on the corner of Whitechapel Road, she runs into Ellen Holland. And Ellen Holland remembers that she was staggering, that she was so drunk that when Ellen stopped her, Polly slumped against the wall. And Ellen tried to persuade her to come with her back to Wilmot's. But Polly said,
“你知道，我不能，因为我没有钱。所以我需要去弄钱。我今天已经拿了三次旅馆钱，但我都花光了。用不了多久我就会回来的。”所以艾伦和波莉说了晚安。她知道是2点30分，因为马路对面有一座教堂。她听到钟声敲响，艾伦看着波莉沿着白教堂路向东蹒跚而行，那是朝巴克斯街的方向，艾伦·霍兰德是最后一个见到波莉活着的证人，当然不是最后一个见到她活着的人，而那个人，凶手，是如何在半小时后与她在一起的
you know, I can't because I don't have the money. So I need to go and get money. I've had my lodging money three times today and I've spent it. It won't be long before I'll be back. And so Ellen says good night to Polly. She knows it's 2.30 because there's a church on the other side of the road. and she hears the chime striking and Ellen watches Polly staggering eastwards along Whitechapel Road which is in the direction of Buck's Row and Ellen Holland is the last witness to have seen Polly alive but not of course the last person to have seen her alive and how that person the murderer came to be with her perhaps half an hour
在她离开艾伦后，在巴克斯街的院子通道旁边，我们不知道。所以有各种建议。哈利在《五人》中的建议是，波莉找到了一个黑暗的角落，蜷缩在那里睡着了，他在她睡觉时杀了她。
after she'd parted from Ellen beside the yard crossing on Buck's Row we don't know so there are various suggestions Hallie's suggestion in the five is that Polly had found a kind of dark corner and had curled up there and had gone to sleep and he killed her while she was sleeping
我会说，普遍的共识是她需要她的旅馆钱，她去那里是为了通过性交易赚取钱，使她能够回到特拉尔街和艾伦一起睡觉，或者也许，也许都不是，也许只是偶然，也许她只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点，你知道，一个醉酒、手无寸铁的女人。我们永远不会确定，但多米尼克，有一件事我们可以确定，那就是波莉·尼科尔斯在凌晨3点15分左右遇到的那个凶残的掠食者。
I would say the kind of the broad consensus is that she needed her DOS money and she had gone there to have sex to earn the money that would enable her to join Ellen in the bed back in in uh on thrall street or maybe maybe it was neither of those maybe it was just opposition maybe she was just in the wrong place at the wrong time you know a drunk defenseless woman we will never know for sure but dominic there is one thing we can be certain of and that is that the the murderous predator who polly nichols had met with around 315 a.m.
我想普遍的共识是她需要DOS的钱，她去那里是为了通过性交易赚取这笔钱，以便能回到索尔街和艾伦同床共枕，或者也许都不是，也许只是因为反对，也许她只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点，你知道，一个醉酒且毫无防备的女人，我们永远无法确定，但多米尼克，有一件事我们可以确定，那就是波莉·尼科尔斯在凌晨3点15分左右遇到的那个嗜血的掠食者。
on the 31st of August 1888 that his reign of terror had only just begun. Craigie, a chilling cliffhanger to end on there, Tom. So next time we'll be back with the investigation of the murder of Polly Nichols and the next link in this terrible chain. Tom, thank you very much. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
1888年8月31日，他的恐怖统治才刚刚开始。克雷吉，这个悬念留得真是令人不寒而栗，汤姆。所以下次我们将回来调查波莉·尼科尔斯的谋杀案，以及这一连串可怕事件中的下一个环节。汤姆，非常感谢。再见。再见。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。